delivery
that seems not normal
honey I think I might have opened a
dimensional vortex just don't throw
anything into it
and now I've done it
hi
a giant probably a bad guy oh this is
adorable
okay calm down
hey stop zapping me with your little
wizard stick it's cold of stuff huh
looks like somebody just got mugged
that's table hey hey hey why don't we
call the truce you guys tell me what's
going on
deal all right fine
perhaps that would be the wisest course
of action okay so here's the deal
there's this real bad dude wears a
helmet
he's been tearing rifts between all the
Lego worlds Wow
I only understood about half of that but
it sounds pretty bad and he's got our
friends so we must return to our quest
to save them
Kulik a quarter
sweet ride Batman still working out the
kinks with a remote function we could
use your help rebuilding our vehicle
stretch no problem let me go make a
sandwich take some time to process
everything that's going on
got it
guess we're on wizard time not bad I
play with Lego a lot and that's our cue
to go
it'll be so kind as to lend me a hand
yes of course top don't forget your
little sappy stick it's called the stuff
yeah I'm good
huh I made some upgrades I do believe it
is now my turn to operate this vehicle
well nice meeting you whatever your name
is I still don't entirely trust you many
thanks for your assistance goodlow giant
no problem good luck
look I think I just swallowed a Batarang